it's a demo gorgon it's a mind flare
it's a giant rat monster well that's a
first
wait a second that monster looks a lot
like Julie Hargrove from the book of
pool I gotta warn you again in you're
banned for life
looks like these insights finally
matched his outsides k-11 trying to dust
off those telekinetic powers of yours
because the upside down isn't finished
with Hawkins Indiana just yet don't let
the fourth of July fireworks distract
you because some new and super strange
creatures are underfoot hat dart a tat
cap no what no stranger things it's
coming to a small screen near you on
July 4th 2019 and we hope you're ready
for fireworks we've got some mine going
Aries lined up for you so don't go
anywhere and Showtime the upside-down
shopping mall continually released brand
new poster for stranger things 3 has got
some serious neon and 80s nostalgia
vibes here's a quick rundown on the
poster and what it means the kids are
together for the 4th of July they all
hang out at the mall
however the mine player is back and
waiting for them in the upside down
version of the mall 11 must use her mind
powers to stop the monsters again and
Billy seems to be in the upside down and
there might be demo rat monsters lurking
about if you add this to the other fan
theory as it all starts to unfold a new
monster we've all seen the titles of the
upcoming episodes in season 3 we'll get
to all of their meanings in a bit for
now we're going to focus on one title to
bite away from her fans are speculating
that Billy gets bitten by a monster the
theory states that after he's bitten he
becomes this sort of hybrid half human
half monster creature fans are pointing
to the movie the thing as their
inspiration for this theory if more
people and animals are infected we could
have all sorts of hybrid monsters
running around some fans are even
convinced that these monsters will be
half human half rats now that's just
gross a major character isn't going to
make it ever since they took Bob away
from us in season 1 we have been worried
that our favorite stranger things
characters might not survive the series
fans are pretty sure we are going to
lose an important character this season
the
it's not he may think it is I can't lose
you again we're talking about Mike yep
you heard that right
Elevens bone apparently the actor who
plays Mike finna Wolford has been very
busy with outside projects so it would
make sense for the creators to write him
out of the show and it would also make
for a very compelling vengeance story
arc for 11 new characters
we checked IMDB and we noticed some new
characters listed for season 3 there are
a few new soldiers and also a Russian
guard in the New Year's Eve trailer we
saw Russian text on the computer screen
and then there is that creepy guy with
the guy in the funhouse of the carnival
could he be a Russian spy maybe the
Russians are after 11 1 fin things the
Russians may even have a member of their
own who's ready to do some damage it
could be someone like collie episode
title clues ok let's break down from
season 3 episode title theories episode
1 is titled Suzy do you copy
with who is Suzy the only person we can
think of is Max's mom and Billy stepmom
Susan Hargrove so is this episode about
Susan if so maybe she is in danger when
finding said Billy might have something
to do with her potential disappearance
episode 2 is titled the mall rats this
is a title with a double meaning xi and
her crew will probably be mall rats at
the new local mall but with all those
rats on the new poster there could be
actual rats at the mall - episode 3
titled the case of the missing lifeguard
probably has something to do with the
new character Heather episode 4 the
sauna test probably has something to do
with the scene in season 2 where the
shadow monster exits wills body after he
is exposed to extreme heat maybe the
sauna toss is used to force the monster
out of their bodies or to test to see if
they have been infected the next episode
of the source is likely about the source
of the monsters in the upside down or it
could be a reference to the Hawkins post
who's building we see in the trailer the
birthday is the title for episode 6 many
fans think that this is a reference to
America's birthday or the 4th of July
the fireworks
could have something to do with the way
they defeat the monsters we already
discussed the theories to the episode
titled the bite then the last episode is
the Battle of Star Court one fan thinks
that this will be an epic battle at the
mall between the Hawkins squad the
upside-down monsters and the Russians
hidden meanings in the New Year's Eve
teaser in this teaser there is a cryptic
message highlighted on the computer
screen
it reads when blue and yellow read the
West some have suggested that this is a
secret coded message about a meeting
time at the Star Court mall if you look
at the giant clock at the mall it has
blue and yellow hands so maybe that's
code for Russians to attach the mall at
8:45 that would be when the blue and
yellow hands meet in the West also 11:00
and Mike are wearing blue and yellow
shirts in the movie poster
BTS book messages there are many
messages in the behind-the-scenes book
that fans have carefully scrutinized but
we are just going to focus on the two
most fascinating ones one is the phrase
the week is long according to Dungeons &
Dragons fans a week in the Forgotten
realm is really 10 days since the upside
down is reminiscent of the Forgotten
Realms this signal is an extended stay
in the upside down for the characters
the other message at trips to China
sounds nice is an indicator that 11 may
be able to teleports to the other side
of the world now that would be amazing
Dungeons & Dragons foreshadowing one fan
pointed out that the season 1 finale of
stranger things could hold clues as to
what will happen in season 3 after they
play D&D they complained that the
campaign was too short and that they had
questions those questions may actually
be clues like what about the last night
to this be referring to 11 or under the
number like Kali the proud princess they
referred to it could be max or another
newer character and what about the weird
flowers in the cave maybe this could be
a clue that we will see the flower face
demo Gorgon again before you go let us
know who your favorite stranger things
character is in the comment section
below don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching the things see
you next time
[Music]